evaluate the following expression when x
is equal to seven and y is equal to one
and we have three x squared plus ten y
plus four so this is the same thing as
negative three times
x squared x is going to be equal to
7. so before we had an x now we have 7
plus 10
plus 10 times y
y is now equal to 1
plus 10 times y and then we have plus 4
plus 4. so this is going to be equal to
this is equal to negative 3 times 7
squared 7 squared is 49 orders of
operations do the exponent first so this
is going to be negative 3 times 49
plus 10
let me write this in green so plus 10
plus 4 this part simplifies to 14. this
part right over here negative 3 times 49
so 3 times 50 would be 150
3 times 49 is 147
this is negative 147. so this right over
here is negative 147. and to that we are
going to add 14 which is equal to
negative one let me make sure i do this
right if i had 147 minus 14 that would
be
133 so it's going to be negative 1 33
negative 147 plus 14
yep negative 133 and we are done